hi my name is Connor price and I'm
research associate at the German
Aerospace Center and the Hamburg
University of Technology this year my
speech will about networking of fuel
cell stacks using wolfram system model
and mathematica
thanks everybody for joining my name is
gonna and I'm a research associate at
the German Aerospace Center at the
institute of engineering thermodynamics
and I basically work on electrochemical
energy technology and today I would like
to talk a little bit about very recent
ideas concerning the networking of fuel
cell stacks which means that in a
typical fuel cell systems you have only
one one type of fuel cell stacks and
compared to battery modules or arrays of
capacitors we were considering of using
more than one stack into a single fuel
cell system and the first ideas I
investigated very roughly using both
arms modeling and simulation suit that
means the software of mathematica and
system modeler the talk will be outlined
I give a brief introduction about the
background of the systems what we are
which we are considering and what kind
of applications and I hopefully can also
motivate the use of considering to have
more than one fuel cell stack into a
single system and then we have a short
look at one can get rid of singles stack
fuel cell systems using system model and
mathematica very roughly and how it is
also possible with the few lines of code
to make a decision whether it's a good
idea to use more than one stack in a
system and I will summarize and give a
brief outlook as young yesterday
motivated me to show some video stuff
which shows our very recent work quite
well so the background is that we are
working on certain kind of fuel cell
system which is called multi functional
system integration that means we use a
fuel cell system not only for providing
electric energy for different purposes
we also use it for providing thermal
energy as well as inner
gasps and product water which are made
from the products the process side
products from the electrochemical
reaction and that means that compared to
a typical fuel cell s electrochemical
energy conversion or a combined heat and
power plant we have several observable
servable products we would like to
control independently and each of these
products which need to be controlled to
a third and demand to a certain load
profile has impact on the other products
as well as on the operating of a fuel
cell itself so that is a kind of tricky
optimization problem with lots of trial
and error um and that's what we are
basically doing and I don't know whether
it's a readable but this is an example
of a fuel cell multifunctional fuel cell
system for future generations of civil
aircraft where he has written typical
purposes for the product that we use the
thermal energy for ice and rain
protection warm water heating also for
the air conditioning electric energy
obviously is used for electric power
supply also autonomous texting when
there is a electric engine in one of the
wheels of the aircraft air conditioning
electric heating we use the product
water of the fuel cell for potable water
process water also for humidification in
the air conditioning and the inert gas
is used for if it's dry inert gas try
dinner because we can use it
continuously for fuel tank inerting and
if it stays wet we can use it we can
store it somehow and use it eventually
for cargo fire protection yeah and to
show that it's not only research we also
have some kind of applications this is
our kind of largest laboratory it's an
Airbus a320 and I think it's not
readable but its large stake are here
on side fuel cell demonstrator and the
fuel cell system is located here it's at
the moment not replacing the
conventional gas turbine-powered
auxiliary power unit it's just so to say
a spare part for testing so that in case
of emergency we can go back to the
conventional systems here maybe some
some of the people from Germany and
Europe at once driven with the scanlines
ferry which is also completely powered
by hydrogen based fuel cell which is
connected also to the heating system and
the onboard power electronics this ship
is quite impressive since there are also
some more advanced techniques like these
flat naruto's for harvesting wind energy
for propulsion here we have one of our
buses from hamburg public transport this
is a high-voltage DC battery power bus
which has a fuel cell range extender and
the most tricky stuff is here that the
on the roof mounted first charging
device so that there are certain bus
stops on its route where there are few
minutes standing time so this bus can
always have an induction rapid charging
mechanism to recharge the battery during
the stop and if it's not enough then the
fuel cell will come up as a range
extender this product is already
commercially available this is a
phosphoric acid powered fuel cell system
which can be used by the industry for
providing electric energy heating energy
also cooling energy by absorption
cooling since this operating
temperatures roughly about 180 degrees
celsius and the inert gas is used for
alerting large rooms and also fire
protection of a special yeah special
locations where it's needed so all of
these
applications use a fuel cell systems
with a single fuel cell each of these
commercially available systems can be
yea sized if you buy two or three that
will need no problem then you have
actually two or three fuel cells itself
but from the operating point of view
they will act as oh behave like a single
fuel cell in the control process so
what's the motivation for considering
more than one fuel cell into a single
system the first advantage might be that
the availability of the cost the
commercial fuel cells available are
available in different sizes and if you
have a specific amount of power output
then it might be cheaper and diffusers
are really available if you can sighs
your system with existing fuel cells and
not have the need to design a special
bond adapted to your requirements that
might save time and cost the reliability
would be a point of view when you have
several fuel cells and one causes damage
it might be that not the whole system
breaks down because there are spare
parts that can take over at least part
of the load maintenance would be one
point because especially for the
stationary applications when there is a
continuous Erie running operation people
often ask whether it might be possible
if you have two fuel cell stack that we
can have the maintenance procedure on
one stack and the other one can go on
with a partial load and the question
also would be are there some
possibilities to improve performance by
having more than one stack and basically
all of these points might be potential
disadvantages if it goes wrong so that
is actually
a point to consider so and let me
briefly mention some points of basic
single-cell fuel cell modeling all
starts with the kind of polarization
curve which has inside the
characteristics of all electrochemical
energy technology I here placed a very
simple one which is basically only
showed the cell potential normed for one
square centimeter dependent of the
current density and here we have
actually the parameter temperature is in
here but I avoided all other parameters
like pressure and and mixtures of the
gases and stuff like this and such
equations are very easy to set up if you
know a little bit about the fuel cell
they have found it can be found in books
and but to fit actually the parameters
that are characteristic for each few
type of fuel cell is not that easy but
in the first step Mathematica always has
some good built-in functions like fine
fit or even fine formula where you work
which can be used if you have
experimental data which are the points
here I collected some specific data from
four different experiments and then you
can fit a polarization curve down here I
think it's not that well readable and
here are the parameters the first fuel
and oxidant actually I choose because of
the type of fuel cell and then the
reference approach a potential is quite
clear because of the reaction between
hydrogen and oxygen and you can see that
many of these parameters can be directly
found by Mathematica by fitting or also
included already in Mathematica like the
gas constant or Faraday's constant which
is quite nice because it also is able to
provide a kind of dimension checking for
you because if maybe someone has already
looked up
kind of polarization polarization curve
for an electrochemical energy converter
and some textbook sometimes there are
pure type of equations within the
argument of logarithmic or exponential
functions which make no sense since that
I mentioned do not count out for each
other so it's sometimes hard to to see
how the people get there and it's more a
phenomenological fitting than kind of
physical fitting at the end from the
Polaroid relation covered can be seen or
that is very bad to read I'm sorry for
that from the polarization curves you
can see actually that the behavior of
such a fuel cell the electrical behavior
needs to be nonlinear so that is the
best place to start using system modeler
to show up how actually the response of
this nonlinear behavior is and it's
actually quite easy if you start with a
polarization curve to set up a model for
single fuel so you can either use the
text mode and just putting in equations
set parameters which you can take from
textbooks or the literature or you can
even directly draw an equivalent circuit
because all of these components are
really available within the modelica
standard library and so in system
modeler and let's see then we can model
and the transient response for example
of the cell potential if we have a
current ramp and there you see
definitely that nonlinear behavior and
actually if you know polarization curve
with the fitted characteristic
parameters and you know a little bit
Allah about this transient response of
the fuel cell for 10
sure you know enough about a fuel cell
to make the first investigations and the
first thought of how to analyze optimize
and improve this stuff so basically
everybody can can start afterwards
trying to build the at least the
electrical side of a fuel cell and the
analyzing that's really bad to see the
analyzing can be already done quite
simple using just the simulation center
of system model a' like yarn and and
patrick yesterday mentioned in their
education course just playing around a
little bit and looking up what the
different behaviors are and try to
understand them and interpreted them for
example you see here maybe you see or
hopefully you see this is the
characteristic polarization curve which
so shows the cell potential involved
over the current density in ampere per
square centimeter this is the fitted
curve from before and if you simply
wrote the draw this curve which shows
the power density so the butt posts were
centimeter over the current density this
is quite typical for any kind of
yourself and then basically most people
will also draw the efficiency curve over
current density which is basically kind
of transia yeah replaced and
characterization curve because there is
a constant relation and so and this is
it shows the motivation by our fuel
cells considered to be quite efficient
and for low load because for very low
current density they show a very high
direct electrochemical conversion
efficiency up to
the theoretical value of up to
eighty-three percent and but what it's
more interesting if you for example have
a look at the efficiency curve over
power density so which shows you the
electrical conversion efficiency over
the power density and that shows that
it's really not that good conversion
efficiency for very low loads and
actually this was the point for starting
to consider more than one fuel cell
systems because in practical
applications at this point you size down
a little bit the fuel cell concern to
your actual load and hybridize it with a
battery or something like this so that
you do not need the view to the future
to be operated in low efficiency ranges
you go here and if your actual load
demand is not that high you simply
charge the battery and quite interesting
this is I have validated most of these
models with an 80 kilowatt single stack
fuel system and the Labrador laboratory
of a certain kind from a Canadian
manufacturer hydrogenic and then I build
up the reference e-test benchet which
has also users of the same type 80
kilowatt in complete but it consists of
two 10 kilowatt and 2 30 kilowatts tax
and if we now compare the different
curves of efficiency over output power
when you see that this curve is actually
the efficiency over power curve from the
large single stack fuel cell system so
we see for example has the highest
efficiency of roughly above and fifty
percent nearly shortly before the
maximum power up of 76 or something like
kilowatt
and here you see that a 10 kilowatt
system actually comes up to the highest
efficiency shortly before 10 kilowatt so
you see that the single system will not
be operated in these regions for example
for upper power of 10 kilowatt you will
have here roughly about ten percent of
[Music]
conversion efficiency and here you will
nearly have 46 or 47 percent and so this
immediately showed the idea of that we
should try to use it and the idea was to
combine these four fuel cells in a way
that when you draw power out of the
system that at the beginning only one of
the system is loaded up to a certain
amount and then some passive components
like diodes or stuff like this and we're
taking one of the others into account so
that we get a curve which follows
roughly such a shape and it's easy to
see that especially in very low areas of
load we get a very high efficiency and
unfortunately I'm not able to show the
the algorithm which gives provides you
the the optimized configuration of diode
ease but I can show you later on and how
we actually used it so because of time I
will just briefly mention that we saw
this trend dynamic transient response of
one of the fuel cells and it's not that
good to see but it's actually here that
we have with a black line the power
output of the complete multi stack fuel
cell system and all of these curves are
the power output of single ones and it
can be shown that
the trendy and responses of each of
these single stacks can be a little bit
unbalanced and the complete output of
the complete system if we have a very
short temporal displacement and between
when we put the dynamic load on each of
these stacks and these pose two things
were quite easy to to to investigate
using system model and a bit of
Mathematica and actually I would have
shown some bit more but the first
results were so good that I had to stop
modeling and we were starting to
directly building a system which looks
like this I'm not sure whether there is
sound but the idea was to take an
aircraft sailing to sailing aircrafts
and building a third wing in the middle
and placing one of these so-called fuel
cell networks as I call it these multi
stack fuel cell systems in there because
and because of these passive components
would also be possible to have a passive
charging and discharging of batteries to
create a kind of direct hybrid system
and this makes this system efficient and
light enough to be able to power such an
aircraft we use here for smaller fuel
cells each of them have roughly about a
little bit more than 11 kilowatt of
power output both with two hydrogen
tanks and two batteries as it shown here
lithium polymer type and also quite
impressive current of up to six hundred
amperes and this for passenger seated
aircraft was intended to go up to 1500
kilos
and it should be kind of technology
demonstrator for short distance yeah
short distance connection aircrafts
between smaller airports and larger
airports or different kind of airports
and in the near future and since I
should not only show that we intended to
build this I can also show since there
are nearly two weeks that we actually
finished to do this so there was
unfortunately a little bit less time to
do more modeling and simulation but due
to some due dates and and some kind of
economic purposes this were project
needed to be finished first and this
aircraft has a very general kind of fuel
cell network installed and it's intended
to serve for the next five years as a
kind of platform I will go on with a
more detailed systematic modeling based
investigation of these fuel cell
networks and its intended that kind of
potentially topologies configurations
operating strategies can be implemented
here and tested and one of our test
pilots was quite happy because actually
this aircraft makes no noise in except
the aerodynamic noises of the fan there
is a completely no noise
and we were able to improve our two to
increase a little bit the pressure
storage pressure of the hydrogen so it
is now able good to go up to two
thousand two hundred kilometers distance
without filling up and basically if you
can increase the pressure of the
hydrogen it's more or less no more
weight since few kilogram of hydrogen
does not take into account very much
roughly about 250 km/h so yeah there
should have been music but I don't know
whether it doesn't work so due to the
lack of time I think I will go directly
to questions there are any thanks a lot
yeah
[Applause]